the four seasons inn is located in west
dover in vermont's beautiful green
mountains
former construction worker sandy
mcdougall purchased the inn which has 14
bedrooms and an adjacent kennel as a
combination of a lifelong dream since i
was a kid i've always wanted to own him
in i always want to be able to please
people and give him a happy experience
this smell really
does me in a little bit yeah
a hair was found a white a dog hair a
dog hair
impossible
this is a dream come true it's a
beautiful end
it's a great place it's a little slice
of heaven i don't know what kind of
stain that is but i don't want to lay in
it well
i thought it was after only two years
sandy's slice of heaven has turned into
hell i need to know why the phones are
not working it's been nothing but
hemorrhaging money the inn's bedrooms
are almost always empty and despite
marketing itself as a dog-friendly hotel
the kennel lies unused currently
standing into the inn cash-wise 1.15
million dollars
out of my
butt
it's terrific i'm glad i was able to
help with that richard's my marketing
director i should be beating the hell
out of him every day cause he sucks
richard what's up with no money coming
in the inn survives with just a skeleton
crew who live in the inn for free
instead of receiving a salary and then i
drink i don't get paid so it's not
really a job it's more volunteering
going to college
jesus where's my money i want my money
i'm not getting paid i hit rock bottom
as of this morning i'm officially maxed
out on three cards and fourteen dollars
in my bank kicking out i'll get the door
sandy is genuinely a nice guy but staff
does not get paid
[Music]
it's terrible
there's
endless complaints about everything kind
of reminds me of the nursing home i
worked at why we get paid the big
dollars
[ __ ] you steve sandy's own worst enemy
is sandy why the hell is the grill on
sandy's best friend is his dog laila who
lives with him at the end layla is an
english setter she's the greeter
she'll come in the dining room she'll
sit at your feet
the guests complain about dog hair
everywhere and it makes them feel
disgusting
dogs have hair dogs have dander dogs
drool i mean
dogs
lick their own butt
you don't want them anywhere around the
kitchen
most days there are more rooms occupied
by the staff than guests and if things
don't turn around soon this dog friendly
inn will have to be put to sleep sandy's
ragged
beaten we all are
if
corn can't save this place four seasons
in is proper [ __ ]
i can't let this hotel
he's running out of time he's running
out of money and he's running out of
energy
this is the death rattle this is it
good god i can't be that screwed up am
i this is exciting i'm back in vermont
heading towards the four seasons in
trust me i've stayed in a lot of crappy
hotels and i'm finally getting to stay
in something sumptuous
and amazing the four seasons in i've
stayed at four seasons all over the
world they're fabulous hotels that
define luxury so this week should be a
dream
[Music]
hello
oh gosh
well it's certainly doesn't look like a
full season to me
jesus
hello i was hoping for a dream but this
place looks like another
nightmare how are your garden my first
name is gordon know what my name is
thank you my name is sandy reception's
calling sick
no she is around i will take care of
that for you okay great happy to uh
check in we have 18 rooms in the end the
rooms are beautiful
what a [ __ ] mess
nice to see the beds be made
i'm surprised i'm still standing after i
opened that door i swear to god i
thought i was going to [ __ ] myself do
you have a room that's actually ready
yes sir jill thank you sir
[Music]
hey
i'm a bit late for the old party
huh sandy hello
oh well
really the one room they don't make up
erin yeah
rob i am pissed off room four is done
and ready to go go up and check there's
just no excuse for not getting the rooms
done on a timely fashion
this is my worst nightmare
sandy
sandy oh hello how are you yeah brother
i was showing you the honeymoon switch
oh hey i'm eric i'm lost sandy
i've lost sandy it's a bit bizarre sandy
is very scared of his his guests he's he
doesn't like when people like talk down
about you know his inn or his food and
stuff like that so he lies in the
kitchen he showed me into the room it
wasn't my edens
yeah well we're yeah we are kind of in
the middle of doing all of them
what do you do i'm the massage therapist
here and i do hula constructing and also
the
just say that yet the hula hoop
instructing wow yeah
and obviously uh a huge demand of a
month for hula hoop dancers right not at
all here in vermont but i don't know i
kind of picked it up and i liked it so
um you got another room for me yes i do
okay great
good hoop instructor wow [ __ ] me that's
the first
ah at least the bed's mate
thank god for that thank you wow this
wallpaper um it's uh it's eye-catching
right it came with the place right
um i have to be honest i mean i've been
very fortunate enough to stay in lots of
four seasons but i haven't seen one
quite like this how long have you been
affiliated ah we're not affiliated with
the four seasons in
oh so you're not four seasons what are
the four seasons in
but you're not four seasons no no
affiliation
can you get away with that legally yep
they call themselves the four seasons
why are the four seasons in
incredible
and next month is going to be the
waldorf astoria lodge no no
no um well i'm going to
unpack educate
[ __ ] me
uh four seasons yeah more like four
shades of [ __ ]
wow
i've just found out that the four
seasons in is about as far away from a
luxury hotel as you can get
i need to find out what's really going
on here
how are you
so how have you been here about five
months i came here uh to do like massage
therapy and stuff but then we didn't
have like a really call for it because
it was slow so i just started
housekeeping do you ever stay here
i do
oh you do yeah i live here
how does that work uh salary-wise i mean
i don't get one
would you mean don't get one
i've never gotten a paycheck you're
joking no so you're kind of scared to
ask him about it
i'm not too wicked excited about not
getting a paycheck but i don't have a
full-on conversation with sandy about it
because i am scared that he's going to
yell at me and i just don't want to take
it god so how can you treat this place
professionally if you're not getting
patient you can't really i guess treat
it for you you can't thank you
bloody hell yeah
no one gets paid
what an embarrassment take it out
i can't believe sandy doesn't pay his
housekeeper oh god no wonder my room was
such a mess
i hope the food here is better than the
rooms
it's lonely in here
where the hell is everybody
hello hello
my name's glenn gwen nice to see you
where'd you pop out off
popped out of the kitchen
gonna get you started with a glass of
water here
hi layla
that's leila she kind of runs the house
here if you haven't met her yet yeah she
seems busier than the owner
um
entrees
i'll have the mushroom ravioli it sounds
delicious let's go for the salmon as
well after that cook with apples finish
with maple glaze and a apple risotto and
you would like that over soda okay great
all right
choose the plastic in order man i'm up
i'm so nervous i'm trying not to puke i
puked last night before service and uh
after service and i'll probably do the
same tonight
apple risotto with the salmon salmon
seared not cooked through you got it
baby i think we're going to knock garden
socks off with the food fantastic all
right well we have some bread for you
what do you think yeah disgusting
it's just so heavy and deli
hey
are you eating
curry bread
you'll eat anything
gordon did not approve of the curry
bread
oh lord sandy being a business owner
with no culinary experience or training
in any way that's what i was saying last
night it's doughy i don't feel that he
should be back in the kitchen working
later
oh [ __ ] i've already gone
stay with me girl
it's only curry bread
i'm hoping these next couple of dishes
are at least
edible
[Music]
sand it
flavor
flavor i'm sure there's going to be a
lot of flavor here
wild mushroom ravioli
the dog just throw up on my plate i hope
not
wow
[Music]
how is it
um
weird
are the pasta's undercooked
jazzar
thank you sorry no it's not your fault
what's the main problems with this place
um management i mean the management is
sandy right yeah i've worked for him and
haven't received checks
oh well
staff have worked hard and not being
paid yeah
wow
jeez that's tough
sandy can be extremely hard
to work with and for
bizarre
and weird
good god can this get any worse
he said it's undercooked okay
all food in-house right now that is
coming off of this menu none of it is
local
none of it is fresh
sandy's menu is garbage
hello good good afternoon customer right
richard oh richard i'm sorry first time
we met and richard you're not a customer
what do you do i work with sandy on
ideas for marketing when was the last
big idea you put into the four seasons
the last big idea we had was purchasing
lift tickets at a discounted rate right
i would have fired you five months ago
coming into the summer what's the next
big plan and i can present plenty of
plenty of ideas but he has to accept him
i'm frustrated i feel that the ideas i
bring to him are helpful they would work
but sandy he's just not listening
and here is your salmon excellent thank
you my donnie enjoy thank you thank you
good god i hope it's at least halfway
good
that is a apple risotto
wow
what a pile of [ __ ]
that sums it up on that plate there he's
as good as chef as he's an innkeeper
[ __ ] useless
i can't believe i've not seen sandy once
through my whole meal what sort of ink
keeper ignores his guests and hides in
the kitchen well if you won't come to me
just give me that knife now
hi guys hi i'm steve dixon steve good to
see you bud bill bill good to see you
too bud
i'm trying to get a grasp on what i've
just eaten
i know you're the owner yes but you're
the head chef as well buzz we're working
together now in town
so you're both head chefs i've i'm
i
i'm not i'm not exactly sure where i fit
in it it's not my menu i'm not doing any
ordering phil was sandy right now a
little thrown under the bust i feel a
little betrayed right now
the risotto was sweet what was in there
apple juice apple concentrate chef apple
concentrate in a risotto
yes sir come on
it's not my menu chef
so this is
all you're doing then
yeah
[Music]
oh my god can i just have five minutes
on it on my own with the owner would you
mind yes sure
[Music]
you know how do you expect something
magical when it's coming out of a
[ __ ] can
23 [ __ ] years i wait to give them
[ __ ] apple juice concentrate i just
feel absolutely destroyed my food is so
much better than what i just [ __ ]
gave gordon
the [ __ ]
and you know how am i gonna go home and
face my kids when they're all proud of
me and i'm like you [ __ ] dogged our
food
you know that's not why i became a chef
[Music]
if you're in the kitchen cooking who's
running the inn honestly i'm here and
i'm busting my butt trying to get it to
where it should be there's no one
running this here
that's the problem apart from being
soulless it's rudderless it's just a
free-for-all you've checked out no i
haven't why would anyone come stay here
because it's a nice place in the country
it's like a house of madness yeah but
it's it starts with you sandy
everyone's saying the management the
management the management
everybody's blaming the management the
management's you
[Music]
what a joke i'm ready to burn the
building down
the one thing vermont's fake four
seasons has gone for it is its beautiful
riverside location lovely what's that
building over there a guesthouse it's a
dog kennel
is it used no the kennel doesn't do
anything
radiant heat floor renewable energy with
pellets in the furnace they cram some
bear it looks like a prison and what's
through here this is a giant indoor play
area for the dogs a play area
i wouldn't put my dog in a place like
this what a waste
but it all looks unused they are geez my
marketing executive sucks i think you're
right
crazy
[Music]
word has gone out that i'm in town so
the four season dining room is full of
customers for the first time in months
here we are dinner is served i feel
sorry for all of them
sandy honestly i wouldn't even feed that
to a dog
or are you familiar with the area you
live in town oh nice with everyone
looking after the restaurant water food
get it out of here i'm tired of waiting
and sandy burying himself in the kitchen
there's no one to look after the inn you
guys checking in we are
so the servers are forced to check in
guests in the middle of dinner service
the room rate's 275.
get that to you right now thank you very
much no problem is that normal there
friday night walking like that you just
charged him 275
can you just go and ask the owner excuse
me sandy yes how much is friday walking
209. okay because desiree told me 275 so
how come nobody knows we need a level of
consistency across the board from now on
300 we're taxed it's a joke
i don't think i've been properly trained
at the desk i feel like i'm training
myself don't apologize to them so it's
209 there right the inn is the busiest
it's been in months but sandy's still
hiding in the kitchen
playing chef oh my god say upstairs
guests are experiencing the unique charm
of the four seasons inn we don't have
any towels and we found some garbage
under the bed there's that and a light
bulb just because i've been really upset
if my dog's eating a light bulb geez i'm
sorry
can't get over the barking background
barking is unnerving
i can't believe an owner turns such a
blind eye to the problems in his inn
i've got to stop him hiding behind the
stove you take two minutes down get a
look at the dining room check on things
do you have any idea what's going on
there right now i'm needed i feel my my
needle is right back here can you handle
this line steve for 30 absolutely
totally has a look at his business
before it sinks any further
is he for real he's an owner not someone
who should be doing what i should be
doing bottom line i've just never seen
this [ __ ] going on before this is
unorganized [ __ ] chaos is what this
is that's somebody who's got their
fingers on the [ __ ] pulse
how was everything
how is everything so far
they laid out the food
being told in the restaurant nothing's
at the level you think it was it's like
getting kicked in the nuts
i feel like i just wanted to run into
the kitchen and hide
sandy avoiding his guess is a mad way to
run an inn but it's the lack of pay
that's crippling his business i have to
confront it head-on let's have five
minutes together in the lounge please
everybody holy jesus
what is about to go down now
who in this room actually gets paid
[Music]
that's why there's no standards because
nobody's getting paid so there's no
responsibilities
[Music]
if you pay peanuts you get monkeys
if you pay nothing you get [ __ ] all
zero
it's not business it's a [ __ ] joke
talk to me sandy honestly gordon oh well
we started off with all the good
intentions and we've had every bump in
the road
because when we started out we started
out wonderfully
stop it
it's an embarrassment stop the lies
there's no lies you were not booming
when you first opened air it out go
ahead nobody believes it sandy where's
your marketing there's nothing to market
so what have you done
for god's sakes man
please
i'm exhausted
it's been nerve-wracking to watch this
go
off in the wrong direction
you can't run a business
with no infrastructure
and you can't have a business
that's got nobody heading it
enough
for one day
i'm gonna pick this up in the morning
night night show i wish i could say good
night
ah truth hurts
i guess i can be one big [ __ ] can't i
now
horrible
and a disgusting smelly pillow
so far my stay at vermont's fake four
seasons has been a huge disappointment
the owner doesn't know his ass from his
elbow oh that's nice the staff don't get
paid
the guests are miserable there's a stain
here next to the bed only later the dog
is happy here i'm hoping a quick dip in
the swimming pool will get my day off to
a better start
does that look like a present from layla
a floating turd
oh my god later did you sit in the pool
there's no way i'm going in there how
about the hot tub
slightly warm
and layla hasn't taken a [ __ ] in it
great news
[Music]
this place has a lot of potential but
only if i can get sandy to stop hiding
from his guests and the problems here
i'm gonna confront him with his worst
nightmare to wake him up to his
responsibilities as an innkeeper good
morning gordon you guys thank you chef
oh well come upstairs something i want
to show you yeah i'm thinking okay he's
gonna show me something wrong maybe the
hole in the wall board by the door
[Music]
good morning morning
no
there's a room full of people i thought
i was gonna pass out
i'm here
to help this place i really need your
honest feedback sir would you mind if we
start with you there was uh a sign that
i liked when we came in about all dogs
have to be on your leash and we had our
dog and we come in and it was
immediately another dog coming at us not
on a leash our dog's friendly but it
always takes a few minutes with new
animals sure i had read that it was dog
friendly
but i thought it was really interesting
that there was a dog laying in the
dining room and as much as we like dogs
i
don't want a dog in where
i'm eating
um i agree i think that's disgusting
there's one last person i'd like to
introduce you to amy loomis
this lady is the general manager of one
of the hilton brand hotels and if
there's one thing this lady knows
is how to run a hotel first impressions
walking in
at dinner there was
dog hair on the tablecloth
dog hair on the plate that we were given
i asked to speak with a manager i was
told there is no manager
we have an owner i said i'd like to
speak with them then i was told you were
too busy
i've never had the complaints that i had
today it's humiliating it's embarrassing
it's like being flogged in the center of
town
[Music]
there's something i need to show you all
i need you all to put a pair of these on
please
you okay
you got a funny color i'm
hot and absorbing everything yeah yes
okay lights off
now this black light shows up bodily
fluids what oh
i see around sir i just started yeah
go right there
[Applause]
oh yeah big one
sandy can you see that yes
yeah i slept on that pillow
um
charging guests to sleep
on such filth is outrageous
the quilt
see the splashes
yeah do you know what that is oh i don't
want it i don't want it i know it begins
with s
yeah and i'm sorry
yeah disgusting but i want to show you
something over by your feet sandy come
over here
you see that
oh yeah the carpet sandy yes
i mean honestly madam your feet are
right on it
look yeah you see that yes
stands on the carpeter i i have no idea
that could be a dog that could be a
human if it's a human good christmas
just when you thought it was safe to
walk in bare feet trust me that has
never ever been cleaned
absolutely disgusting oh yeah yeah yeah
please take your glasses off
chef we have
another day to stay here today and
tomorrow
and after seeing
the light
i don't want to stay here tonight i
don't want to put my head on that pillow
or any of the other pillows
[Music]
no one would return and the existing
guests that we have
want to check out
thank you madam please thank you you're
looking at a room full of customers who
are looking at you saying i can't
believe you put me in there
and that's maddening
and it's embarrassing
i need some fresh air
i feel sick
[Applause]
it sucks to know where i am right right
now
it's horrifying
it does hurt me inside the tears just
keep coming out of my face
it's not what i wanted
i'm mortified
it's been a tough few days at the four
seasons in
um do we have another room because i'm
not going to be staying in here the food
is [ __ ] hideous
this black light shows bodily fluids
absolutely disgusting i don't want to
stay here tonight i don't want to put my
head on that pillow the truth has been
hard for sandy to hear but he's finally
realized the damage that hiding from his
customers has caused now that i've
opened his eyes i've got to figure out a
way to make his business work hello
leila so that sandy has no excuses not
to pay his staff
you have so much weight on your
shoulders and you're being totally
oblivious to what your customers need
you cannot running in
from behind a stove
you're not the head chef you're the
innkeeper
and that can be a an amazing job that
could be an amazing prospect that can be
an exciting role trust me i am ready i
spent last night crying
there's no lie
this was a dream since i was a little
kid this is what i want i love what i do
but i would love to get back to where i
should be as an innkeeper you have a
potential
gold mine here
embrace it
okay yes sir i know it's hard yeah you
it's normal to get upset
but just embarrassed get qualified yes
head on my ass and absolutely start
building a dream
we're gonna make this work thank you sir
okay
with sandy committee to change
it's time to get the crew involved
let's go and have a couple of minutes
outside from the terrace uh
they have some very important breaking
news
this man
from this day on
is not
the head chef
this man is going to become the in
keeper
no longer will he be burying his head
inside the kitchen
ignoring issues
he'll be running his in
you
are a chef
and this is your general manager
and as a reminder to make sure
we step forward and not backwards
he is not going to be needing these
[ __ ] things
say goodbye to sandy's chef coats
[Music]
[Applause]
burn that thing get rid of that thing he
has no business wearing it
you may
be a great guy but you are not a [ __ ]
great chef let's get that right
there's a big difference there is
gordon coming here has opened my eyes to
my shortcomings i love what i do and i
need to start doing it
got it yes sir there are some very big
changes coming tomorrow
embrace them get ready for it
[Music]
this inn has been neglected for so long
but now i'm finally giving it the
makeover it truly deserves
come on girl good morning good morning
garden wow sandy you look incredible
thank you sir i feel great
how you doing i feel liberated to be
honest with you
you're great oh with the fresh shave new
haircut i feel amazing i feel like a
million dollars i feel like what i spend
on my end what do you guys think of your
new innkeeper
you look like a proper innkeeper and an
owner
right when i first arrived i drove into
the four seasons inn but this
establishment is a one-off it's not part
of a chain right no sir so you deserve
your own name your own identity and
something that you can be proud of
everybody is gonna know you now as
welcome
laters riverside lodge
great rooms fresh food and luxury
kennels
that is amazing layla's riverside lodge
is amazing the name's awesome the sign's
beautiful it's just uh it screams me
what do you think i think it's
absolutely perfect and represent
something so meaningful to sandy you're
absolutely right you okay yeah be sure
i'm positive yeah layla what do you
think
should we go inside love to
this is the new reception area why have
a look at this
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
wow
so
let's welcome
our guests in to a proper
reception area this is inviting this is
warm i love it this isn't
breathtaking is it lovely
gorgeous if you have an inviting lounge
then you need the menu to go with it
gents come through please i've created a
farm-to-table menu of fresh food that
will give people a warm and friendly
vermont welcome
i've revamped the entire menu let me
tell you about some of my favorites
homemade country pate i mean look where
we are look at the farm surrounding the
inn how do you not have a stunning
country pate
wonderful poutine done with a braised
pork shoulder stunning chicken pot pie
easy to execute for the kitchen baked
job done and then our stunning vermont
cheesecake oh my god how you feeling
very hopeful for the future now are you
happier now that sandy is out of the
kitchen i am absolutely ecstatic
that sandy is out of the kitchen the
menu is absolutely perfect
all right now don't be shy
oh my god
wow that pasta is a world of difference
about it before when people ask me where
i worked i used to hang my head and sing
the four seasons
i'm not gonna do that no more
i can look them right in the eye and say
i work at layla's
[Music]
it's gonna be good
i'm delighted they like the new name and
new menu i can't wait to see what they
think of the bedrooms
oh my god
wow
gone is that hideous wallpaper
replaced with this stunning wooden
feature
oh i love the deer oh awesome i love
that
we have steamed the carpet so go on are
those hideous stains we have a luxury
bed for the dog and what i was more
depressed with than anything was the
linen was hideous
we have replaced the bedding
in every room of your end with a hundred
thousand dollars
of
organic linens
ah
you happy
you happy started
that's really overwhelming
do you want to see another room i'd love
to this one you're gonna love
welcome
room three
look at this
gone are those flimsy bunk beds give
your guests some space it's something i
would want to check into
i love the new rooms they're amazing i
actually can't wait to clean them
i'm really excited about how everything
came together there's one more exciting
thing i've got to show you something
that i feel
can transform this business
you ready oh yes sir let's
go i've just revealed the new
improvements to sandy's inn however
there's still one more surprise i have
for him that will really put layla's on
the map
welcome to the thing that makes your
lodge unique
[Music]
a new and improved dog kennel oh my god
amazing i'm stunned
[Music]
wow we've doubled the size of these
kennels we've made them feel luxurious
we have beautiful brand new bedding when
i first arrived these kendalls felt like
a prison now it feels like a reward or a
treat
any dog lover want their dogs to stay
even me i'd bring my
whole dog's hair do you wanna join me
run paul run paul oh
hello mate
hello bud
there he is
rupaul meet layla come on hello
look oh yeah hey look at you who's that
who's that hey guys
oh yes
huh
how gorgeous
now
this part for me is one of the most
exciting parts come this way
please come in
my
god i've never seen the kennel with that
many dogs and that many people
the dogs are here because we've
organised a dog agility competition oh
no kidding wow and all the owners are
going to be checking in and staying in
the inn this evening wow
this kind of event can be done every
month which will drive dog enthusiasts
to come and stay in your stunning lodge
sounds amazing
so we're we've livened the place up
giving it warmth yes
and sandy this is shannon hagum you may
recognize this lady
she is a luxury boarding kennel
consultant she
has very kindly donated to you
ten thousand dollars worth of
consultancy that she's going to help
implement and get this business off the
ground
now let's get back to the end thank
you
with a delicious new menu and a name of
its own layla's riverside lodge is ready
to open its doors and show off its
stunning new look
ladies guys this is the night that we
come back from the dead
we've been afforded all the tools a
great front of house a great bacca house
we're going to make this rock yep
if we blow this we're we're screwed
good evening and welcome to layla's my
name is sandy i'm your innkeeper hi
follow me i'll take you to your room
thank you here we go
oh wow the renovated rooms are a big hit
with a new guest i can't wait to get
under the sheets let me try this
oh yeah she's got a place where she can
just kind of hang out and just you know
be herself right by the window she can
look at the pool and she's got her own
porch look at that wow this is awesome
dinner's underway it's to die for isn't
it and at last sandy is spending time
with his hotel guests and letting his
chefs do the cooking good evening how
was everything it was crazy fantastic
tonight is the best night we've had here
there wasn't one complaint there wasn't
one plate with food left on it is the
difference between last time that we
were here
and this time it's just phenomenally
different
thanks thank you
well done steak in the oven love the
communication yeah tonight it actually
is like cooking in a real kitchen no
sandy back there everybody's trained
everybody's on the same page we got
great food everything from scratch 7 16.
absolutely big any concerns good we're
good babies that's what i want to hear
and while sandy's human guests are
loving the food his canine guests are
finding lots to love as well so welcome
to the new channel wow right
cherry
that's nice you got friends it's
fantastic
you have to be thrilled it's beautiful
i'm on cloud nine i hope to ride this
high for many years to come i mean
it's pretty awesome
this in is finally on the right track so
it's time for me to say goodbye all
right well done good job thank you yeah
really good job indeed and uh do not
let him back in this kitchen no sir okay
rice tough one
we had our highs and lows but you are
really starting to
grasp potential one more surprise
everybody's going on payroll tomorrow
everybody they're all going to have a
paycheck every week really yes that's
music to my ears i'm pleased to hear it
listen good luck thank you sir
take care
gordon save my lodge saved my ass saved
my life
sandy's running around like a
new man he's starting to look and sound
like an innkeeper and if he keeps this
up
this
gorgeous inn
can become an amazing place for a great
weekend
let's go come on come on bye
come on you can't stay come on
come on i know the room's nice but we've
got to go home come on
you lazy [ __ ] come on we gotta go
we have to go i know it's comfy come on
you young man are lazy
home sweet home i know this way come on
come on
good boy
let's go
here we go
yes
do you know where i'm hold
sometimes you can teach an old dog new
tricks or at least make him take a bath
[Music]
good morning layla's riverside lodge
since my visit business at layla's has
been booming and everyone is sharing in
the in success it's 500 bucks
tomorrow w-2 how do you rock okay
thanks we got a great team
and you're part of it my staff means the
world to me every week you get paid
fantastic
that's all i ever wanted to hear man
cause it's a team effort you got to have
people that believe in you
every week you get a paycheck thank you
no thank you
thank you gordon from the bottom of my
heart
years
it hadn't been for you i would not be
here
that's the truth
thank you
and now all the staff are back in sandy
to make layla's riverside lodge a
success oh
rich you said you take it for the team
brother here we go finally with
something to market richard has taken
his sales technique to a whole new level
oh yeah baby
come on rich let's go have a look at the
side
wait come come come here and hold my paw
[Music]